hey everyone welcome to the GameSpot
theater for a panel with the dumb name
head that I thought was cool in the
planning process and no one stopped me
from making it final
it's called microtransactions are great
or are they so one thing I had 4
exclamation points originally and they
ended it down to 3 so there is some kind
of yeah so my name is andy mackay i'm an
associate editor at GameSpot Australia
she could tell I'm American I moved here
back in March I've been here for about
six months but I was working I've been
working for GameSpot for about six years
so just a transition in that role and my
job is just to write news for GameSpot
on a day-to-day basis so yeah thank you
so much for coming today I know it's you
know the very last day of pax and it's
in the afternoon so I really appreciate
everyone coming out this panel as you
probably read is going to talk about
microtransactions you know how they
started why they're controversial how
each of our panelists games implements
them and where the future might be for
microtransactions and I really want to
leave time at the end for a question and
answer session so if you're you can
start thinking about questions now and
once we get toward the end you could
start lining up but so yeah you tried to
get together a you know a great lineup
of panelists for this panel so if you
guys could just introduce yourselves I
think I'd be great to start
sure so my name is Luke dick and I'm
director of central and strategic
analytics citizen gay it's a title that
I've only just getting used to I had two
days on the job and then I pissed off on
vacation for a couple of weeks I've been
asking for three years as a data
scientist and prior to that I was a grad
student doing kind of artificial
intelligence and games research cool so
hi I'm Alex DiGiorgio I'm the regional
product director for world of tanks for
Asia and yeah that's shorter and I'm a
Mahal
one of the cofounders of hipster whale
we are responsible for Crossy Road
pac-man two five six and Disney Crossy
Road that's right let me hear it yeah
local team
so I I want to start off by asking the
audience who here has spent money on
micro transactions okay I guess that
makes sense that's why you're here great
huh
so to start off I think think we might
be it might be good to dive into a
definition so I know micro transactions
can mean different things in different
contexts to different games so but
before we get into how they're used in
your specific games sorry if we could
have the kind of let's talk about the
definition of micro channels Jack's and
what does it mean to you Lukie if you'd
like to start okay so I mean a micro
transaction to me is something at the
end of the day it's a thing that keeps
the game going and what I mean by that
is there have been models in the past
where it's been a subscription model to
support kind of server costs and the
costs of actually running the game to me
a micro transaction is a way of kind of
supporting the development of the game
in an opt-in kind of way with a lower
kind of bar territory that maybe a
$15.00 whale subscription or something
like that so that's what I think of when
when kind of term comes up to me pretty
similar but I would from my side I would
just say that it's a weight off of value
in different ways for different players
who would like or expect different
things from from their games and we want
to offer choice and I think
microtransactions is a way to enable us
to do that without necessarily impacting
the core game and the core game design I
find um looking microtransaction off and
like I feel that quite similar to DLC
like I don't really separate them in my
mind too much I just think it's
something you bet pay for after you've
downloaded that or you know paid for or
downloaded the initial game for free
that's the way I look at it okay great
thank you and then we're also looking at
um you know I also want to ask you guys
about how your specific games the games
that you've worked on implementing micro
transactions I know and what kind of
variation do you see is like say for you
know World of Tanks vs world of warships
Alexei if you'd like to start just
talking about so for us obviously we
offer it's a free to play free to enter
there's no upfront costs the the way
we've implemented Prime
transactions is in in our in-game
economy so basically we offer as players
play through the game we have there an
experience on different tanks and they
also earn credits from those tanks which
allows them to then upgrade their tanks
purchase new tanks and so on so it's
basically based on this concept of
buying new tanks going up bigger and
better and stronger tanks as you go
through sort of the tearing system that
we have and that's the fundamental
around our economy and it's also about
basically you can do that without
spending anything or you have we have a
sort of a premium model where you can
earn experience and credits faster in
each battle by paying some level of fee
okay and then Matt if you'd like to talk
about just because I know cross the road
and pac-man they handle a micro
transactions in a different way yeah I
mean we we highly experts on the field
we've with Crossy Road the idea was was
a lot of talk about best practices with
with free-to-play games than we laughed
at the idea because the you know micro
transactions had only been around for a
few years and our approach with micro
transactions and advertising was that
I'm sure you know we felt that no one
had it figured out so we wanted to try
and advertising advertising first game
and micro transactions were just and
then you know in addition to that but
we're continuing to play around with
micro transactions in in all of our
future titles and figure out if there's
a different / better way yeah that's a
good point is that you know when we
launched World of Tanks free-to-play
really wasn't a very common thing it
wasn't something that was a well it was
becoming the flood of flavor but it was
still very much your box
titles playing premium ping premium
prices for them or as you mentioned
sativex subscription models and so on
for the mmo's space so we were kind of
figuring things out as we went along
you know what works what doesn't and I
think we're still doing that so I think
for us micro transactions it's never a
sort of a stable concept it's constantly
evolving and what we see is micro
transactions now
maybe four or five years online it'll
we'll be looking at different things and
coined those microtransactions sort of
constantly evolving and I'm from zingers
perspective obviously your games are a
little bit different than you know
hipster Wales games or World of Tanks
this is very true we've been around for
over ten years though so I think we've
tried every model going at some point or
another with varied amounts of success I
think is very true in the like I think
it is almost to call an arms race would
be a bit of a pejorative but the markets
evolving and what I mean by that is that
consumers tastes are changing and
they're kind of changing how they're
willing to pay for things and what they
see the value in and we're having to
adapt to that so you know maybe roll
back the tape maybe seven years and you
would pay for additional lives or energy
and these horrible mechanics that are on
Facebook and they fell out of favor and
now it's headed towards more sort of
maybe it's kind of loot boxes or it's
new ways of progressing or it's new kind
of faster ways of progressing through
the game you know heroes of the storm is
a good example of that way of paying for
extra experience per game that kind of
leads into my next points here just
about I think one of the things that
people usually talk about in terms of
microtransactions and things you can buy
is a cosmetic versus items that actually
affect gameplay so in a World of Tanks
experience how do you balance you don't
want to probably give you you don't want
to have someone have a pay2win advantage
so how you balance that
I mean look World of Tanks is it's PvP
15 vs. 15 competitive gameplay so
balance is kind of like our daily you
know livelihood and at the same time we
are offering you know premium tanks and
unique tanks and so yes it's something
that we're constantly having to adjust
we're balancing more than 400 tanks in
our games which offer different game
mechanics different styles of play and
when we offer a new premium tank for
example the first thing that you know
any player that's seeing that in a shop
is gonna say is well is that tank if I
buy that tank does that just mean I'm
just gonna be able to win every battle
and the
is to be able to say no it's still based
on skill I'm team play and everything
but these premium tanks will offer some
kind of unique gameplay some kind of
strength
maybe that suits your style or it's a
visual something visual you aesthetic
you like about it so that's where we
kind of focus is we do want to offer
those those options for players who want
them but they should never break the
gameplay so it is cosmetic gameplay in
terms of fitting to your particular
style but they don't offer you specific
and like an overall advantage where it
just there's no chance for you to lose
we constantly look at that and balance
that and then from your perspective Matt
I know with you know Crossy Road you're
not paying extra to buy a character
that's better then then than any other
one it's basically just a skin but if
you could just talk about your
philosophy toward yeah we wanted to do
it that way we have an interesting story
there were Andy and I were were really
adamant that what was more important
than making money was people sharing the
game with their friends and we felt that
if you made any one character better
than any of the others people would you
know go towards that character and would
reduce the talking point instead we
really wanted people to say hey I got
the flee isn't this awesome I got 300
points with a flee and no matter which
character we you were using it was
always going to be the same in fact some
of the skins made the game harder to
play so if you like Frankenstein turns
everything black and white miss storm
going on it's a hard mode when you're
playing with with Frankenstein's monster
but then when Disney Crossy Road came
around we you know reevaluated that like
that was something we absolutely wanted
to do but with Disney cross he wrote as
a chance to experiment and say well was
this really the right thing to do so we
did have characters that increased your
score and did sharing go down because of
that it's impossible to measure but that
was a big difference between the way we
approach those two titles and then you
at each mentioned the you've you know if
you've experiments it with different
microtransaction systems and models so
you just talk about the feedback that
you've heard from players and have you
ever you know changed something directly
as a result of what you know has been
said about your game
we've we've we've crossed erode we got
pretty much a universally positive
feedback it was really to stop to us to
try to make things things better we
didn't with regard to reacting to the
players we would often just do that
through Twitter we would see what are
people talking about or what they like
or what they don't like and just filled
with things that way we weren't we
weren't really optimizing for money we
were optimizing to make sure that people
had a great time and would tell their
friends about it as his bigger numbers
as possible yep
is anything you want to add to that I
mean from our side
I think the model that we we actually
we've built the game on is has you know
it's been something we've been building
alongside our players for a long time
now and we haven't really made massive
changes or flip-flopped around that
we've kind of stuck with it because our
players reacted well to the way we
design the model you play the game the
way you want to play it and so since
then now over the last few years we've
started to look at you know what else
can we do can we start to evolve this
can we just actually simplify some of
these mechanics you know as you build on
these things there's a there's a
tendency to overcomplicate systems and
so now we're looking at potentially you
know can we actually streamline some of
these make them easier to use these are
the discussions that are happening but
fundamentally at the moment our players
like the way that we approach um at
least that's what they tell us and you
know we do listen to player feedback and
we have you know community gatherings to
talk about things like like that and so
it's a constant process right now we
haven't you know we're not seeing any
need to make major changes but we will
look to tweak as necessary so when we
first started every character was a
dollar and it remained that way for a
few weeks until we realized no one
really knew what to buy because every
character was identical what do they do
you know is there any value to doing
this and we were suffering like players
were suffering like paralysis of choice
so within the first six they could
basically our first major patch we
introduced the piggy bank
which was three times the price it was
up front and then had the additional
benefit of increasing the number of
coins you get in game and that instantly
became out our biggest seller and and
greatly increased our revenue and made
the game better so you know it'll work
that really well then maybe this is more
of a cynical question - but you had
spoken about how you want to make your
micro transaction systems you know
player friendly and I'm putting that
experience first but how do you how do
you do that in practice when you're you
know I could see behind the eyes maybe
you know you see dollar signs
potentially lighting up so how do you
keep yourselves humble and you know
wanting to be you know player driven
first yeah it's true to an extent we
have to earn that and it's something
that we have to be conscious of you know
we have to be aware that the dollar
signs you know not only do we see them
the players see us seeing them and that
has you know it speaks to the same kind
of evolution of the market if you are to
cynically grabbing for the dollars
eventually players will punish you for
that and you know thing has been around
long enough that we've been through the
ABS and flows of punishment with that
and I think we're back to a really good
place now
potentially you guys will tell us
different probably at some point but
right now I you know we've got a very
strong internal kind of team that is
keeping track of player feedback very
good at passing that back to do to the
design teams and you know some of the
choices that we made even ten years ago
we're locked in to today but at the same
time we're also evolving you know it
it's something that will count us off
with our new titles in particular where
we have the opportunity to kind of be
very money-hungry or walk a better calf
and I think I think hipster whale kind
of is really showing where that better
path was mountain goat Mountain is a
title that we released
maybe two years ago which was very
similar in there it was monetized solely
through skins
there was no clever piggy bank there was
no nothing and it didn't do the best it
could have done if we'd been able to
kind of slip things like that into it so
the there is definitely a compromise to
be made between you know we need the
dollars but maybe we don't need to be
hanging you up by your toes and kind of
beating them out of you at the same time
so we've we've tracked man to five six
we were far too generous with that title
because it man you know per user it made
so much less than then cross he rode did
and we were just trying to feel out
within ourselves like where where's the
icky factor like what what feels like
the wrong thing to do and and with with
pac-man we just didn't go far enough
there was not enough things for people
to buy
we weren't motivating them to stick
around long enough and so we got a huge
number of downloads but you know we
definitely would have been happy with
that Idol if it had also been a big big
financial success so yeah we made the
missed you know everyone makes mistakes
and we went too far one way yeah so
there's an expectation I think when you
spend money on you know anything be that
a you know a virtual item or you know
whatever your you know dinner you're
having that you have a fair transaction
so how do you walk that line I know you
talked about in terms of you know fan
feedback but do you actually work with
like economists you know to figure out
how you want to price things and what
things you want to sell or you know
behavioral patterns is that how far down
does that go in terms of nailing down
the price points and the things you want
to sell sure I mean yeah we we drilled
right into the data so we have teams
that that's what they focus on and
they're you know their day to day is
looking at what are we selling what is
our how does our economy look you know
our players actually buying these things
there's it does it look like they see
value in what we're offering in the game
and if they do they're not and we don't
and we're not selling them then we
remove those and we look to okay how the
next time we want to approach that kind
of transaction how do we price it so
these are these are things that we're
doing all the time it's a huge part of
what we need to do to make sure a our
economy stays consistent as we bring new
players in as
well who maybe have different likes and
dislikes you know I mean we have we've
been fortunately we have a very strong
core of players playing World of Tanks
I've been playing for many years their
expectations are different from someone
who's just starting the game today and
who's just trying to figure out if this
is the game for them so figuring out
what's the right type of way to approach
those players versus players have been
playing with us for five years that
again is like it's another level of the
dynamic you have to look at and make
sure that there's value for those
players and value for the players who've
been who've already bought every tank in
the game and and owned everything what
can we offer to them because they do
want to buy things and this is again
coming back I think to your point is
that you know it's not just about trying
to get them trying to find things to
sell it's trying to find things the
players want to buy I want to find
things they love the games and they want
more stuff how do we give it to them at
the right price and that doesn't affect
the game or break the game it's like the
things I've been fan of a big fan of
over the years not necessarily video
games I want to as a fan contribute to
the to the success of that thing and as
a game developer you need to make sure
that you have those things so that
someone who absolutely loves everything
that you do can can help you out and
help you make more things and if you
don't give them the opportunity to share
or buy then you know it's said it does
the game a disservice yeah and sort of
going back to the other point you made I
mean did our games are super social I
mean where we're living in that
environment now players talk to each
other about everything including what we
sell and what we're offering in the
games and you know if enough players see
that there's not enough value in
something that we're selling they're
gonna talk about it they're gonna talk
about it with each other and they're
gonna share that and so it's not
something you can sort of hide behind
and expectations change so frequently I
mean you know from that from my point of
view as a consumer my attitude to
microtransactions has been like a roller
coaster over the last five years it's
like what did they do then yeah two
years later we put that in our game it
feels a little
it feels that because it's become okay
and then like how do I feel about like
overwatch loot boxes like I really like
their implementation of that maybe I
don't like it in other games it's it's
really weird it's like a game minute the
feel yeah and again it's because maybe
you feel a certain connection to a game
yeah that even if you bought it and it's
a premium title you still feel yeah I
want to spend more in that title I want
to be more involved in and maybe you
don't maybe like that's it I've spent
enough and that's good enough for me
yeah it is title yeah so obviously
probably a reason why a lot of people
here today is you know microtransactions
systems are highly controversial as
people have been talking about on this
panel and at large every time we write
about microtransactions on gamespot the
comments are many many more than on a
typical story I'm much more spirited I
guess I would say so why do you think
people get so you know hung up or not
hung up but get so worked up about micro
transaction systems I know it does it
come down to you know this is it's their
money in their pocket that they're good
they're you know handing over to you so
that's obviously very important to them
but why do you think just you know
people get so worked up if you like to
start
I mean for me the thing that I feel
occasionally and see in the comment
sections on websites is people really
don't like the idea of having content
being gated behind paying more and they
feel that you know I paid for the game
why do I have the entire game which is a
point of view and possibly you know it's
a certain certainly a decent enough
stance it gets into a little bit more of
the kind of okay but it costs something
to run this game and all the things that
I started from I think but I feel like
it's not just the doors in the pocket
it's also this kind of but but this
whole thing should be something that I
have access to I don't know maybe you
guys have different I do I like I'm a no
I've been playing games for a really
long time and you know the first deals
Eve that ever came along I remember
feeling a little yeah why doing this I
paid for that same game last year for
this amount and now you but I you know
after reflecting games of
in you know $50 $100 for the last 20
years you know but the the cost of
making these games has absolutely
skyrocketed like that you know more
people are coming in and playing them so
it's making this okay
but that curve does not fit we can
either a triple-a standpoint you can
either okay we're going to keep our
budgets flat at this point onwards
because no more people are coming in and
playing games or and and that will
result in a stagnation of quality we're
all expecting Triple A games to get
better year after year and they keep
they keep doing that but it's just
unsustainable so you can either play
shadows of war and but buy a few extra
buy a few loot boxes or get a smaller
scope game next year yeah I mean that's
it's the other side of the coin right
then the development costs continue to
rise games get better and better deeper
and more complex and expectations rise
alongside so it's it's not it's never
gonna I don't see that ending not
anytime soon but as you said you know
when I first started buying games it was
yeah and you were from 70 to 80 dollars
or and and it's sort of stayed there and
stayed flat in some cases declined
doesn't really make sense but when
you're as a buyer if they gave me like
great you know I can get this even
bigger game on this on the new platform
and but then something has to give way
and so they're trying to figure that out
the DLC was an attempt to figure out
well we can still offer the core
experience but you know if you want
extra content okay well that's something
someone else has to work on you hold and
develop and then we can sell it
separately I hated it when DLC came out
I was like what is this I don't want to
spend more money on this I have more
games that I want to buy and yeah other
games that I want to spend time on
that's the danger too I mean if you
don't like if you annoy your customers
there are so many games to move to
migrate to and so it's it's a something
we have to be all triple-a gamers we
don't you know if you're experimenting
that space it's it's something you do
have to be careful with I remember um
Jason Rubin came out here in 2004 and he
was the head of Naughty Dog
and showed a chart of what crash
bandicoot took to make and then what jak
and daxter took to make and then what
jak to talk to making just had this and
I couldn't believe it like it was like
how could a game possibly take ten
million dollars to make it now they're a
hundred yeah it's a it's absolutely
insane numbers given the games cost the
same now as they did back then so I kind
of didn't want to drill down into that a
little bit more just the economic
realities of developing games today I
know you guys had just spoken about you
know gamers are always asking for higher
fidelity more features and that
obviously comes with a you know a price
tag that's higher than it was before so
in terms of our micro do you see micro
transactions and dlc and expansions and
things like that as a you know a natural
next step that is you know what helps
those games you know stay profitable are
we gonna just is that we're gonna see
more and more of this in the future
maybe it's an unnatural next dip yeah I
mean from my perspective look World of
Tanks is it's it's not just well how do
I say this it's a game that continues to
exist 24/7 we have players playing all
the time at all times of the day and we
have to service those players and we
have to you know be there for the
players our community guys have to be
there our customer service people have
to be there it's a whole you know
economy behind the game that we have to
support and that's not gonna go away
because we want to continue to support
the game and we expect the game to
continue to grow and so on so that's our
reality and that's how we build our our
business as well as around that is that
we're not just here's a game ship it
okay support it for a while but we've
got the next game coming out so we need
to start focusing our resources on that
it's like this is our game and and we're
supporting it all the time so that's
from our perspective and being a free to
play that's where we are now as a
natural evolution whether that's the
same for you know triple-a titles that's
the separate to me that's it no I look
at them very differently just from how
they operate their their economics and
you know with with free-to-play games
you guys are all you know experts in
that field you know
war gaming hipster well the the games
are I feel like democratic in a way with
in that you know if you don't like it
you can just you know you won't spend
money on it you'll go off and and do
something else so that must actively
encourage you to create you know the
best possible content because if you
don't people will leave so trying to
find a question in that just the idea of
you know creating content that people
are going to want to pay for how do you
go about doing that like how do you find
out how do you discover you know what
people really want and then put it out
before them if I knew that then I have a
hit game every time I mean from our
point of view like being a data
analytics guy that is kind of
effectively my bread and butter is what
are people reacting to what are they
buying what are they spending where are
the other staying in the game still are
they leaving and kind of using our
insights into the game to kind of walk
back to you know from symptoms to
Diagnostics basically and then we
surface recommendations to the team
based on that so that gives us kind of
we get the insight from the numbers and
that insight is kind of passed to design
teams and product managers who can turn
those numbers into okay well we did this
and everything tanked we should not do
that again
until next year when all the
expectations change well next year it'll
be somebody else's problem rotated round
and there will be no institutional
learning so it's all good yeah um he's
laughing because he knows I mean from at
the end of the day it still just comes
back to the game itself if it's fun and
people want to play it they're gonna
keep going back to it they keep gonna
looking to open up new elements and play
more of the game and that's we still we
shouldn't forget that like everything
else that we do around it is us trying
to be smart and clever figure out how to
to to sort of best manage the game but
if it's not fun and people don't play it
people won't have fun with it and don't
enjoy the experience they'll go
somewhere else
it's it's a game you know so if she's
trying to get too far away from that I
think you get yourself into trouble and
another thing that is often you know
discusses the term Wales so the idea
that someone will spend a lot of money
sometimes an absurd amount of money
there was a new story recently about
someone who spent fifteen thousand
dollars on Mass Effect 3 in terms of the
extra cars that you could buy for that
game so I'm just wondering if you could
talk about do you see this kind of
behavior in your game or is this just
like a story that gets you know blown
out of proportion every time it does how
like are there actually whales living
inside apart from hipster whales are
there actually whales in in your games
hipster whale was named for this
phenomenon we were making fun of it
slightly hungover one day at a game
conference and that's how he came up
with the company name we with Crossy
Road that was a deliberate attempt to
make a non whale game there is no way to
be a whale in in cross he rode the most
you can possibly spend is by every
character and congratulations you're out
$100 I mean it was it was never the
intention for that title and and we
specifically wanted to make a little bit
of money from everyone rather than a lot
of money from some people but like
that's that's for Crossy road I mean we
we are definitely interested in in
pursuing alternate you know in chasing
whales I guess a little bit with with
some of our other titles but it really
depends on the audience and what you're
making and it also requires so much more
work to try to make a game you know with
Crossy Road we just had to make a fun
game and get people to watch ads along
the way I mean it wasn't it wasn't that
difficult we didn't need to play around
with you know funnels and making sure
that this person feels motivated to
spend at this exact time you know we
made that game in in three months and we
were just lucky had sort of it worked
our methodology worked but we will will
be making different types of games in
future then I was at the panel yesterday
Alex of yours for World of Tanks and I
know there was one gentleman who stood
up and said he's probably spent he
didn't say a number but it sounded like
a lot of money on your game over the
years so what's your
reaction when you hear something like
that because I can't imagine that's very
normal you know what can you say I'd say
thank you I mean it's great obviously
when we have you know guys who are
willing to or want to you know spend
that amount of money in our games and
those are people with disposable income
right yep right and it's a choice they
make you know they see the value and
they want to own them and and and yeah
we were very grateful them I think if
you start whale hunting and if you start
going out there specifically building
games for that kind of to try and
capture that then you get yourself into
trouble again because you know it should
be a secondary reaction to something
they're feeling of I love this game
when I'm in this game this is what I
want to be spending my time and money on
and I can so I do if I need the whales
play it would be a very very thin game
you would have yes guarantee people
playing tell me one of the things that I
think having join Zynga three years ago
the one of the sort of cultural shifts
that had already happened by the time I
got there is that we don't talk about
whales internally you know we do have
VIPs in our game but we refer to them as
VIPs I think that is something that is
it's a more of a cultural change and
kind of just that shift of kind of
psychology this is not somebody who were
hunting this is somebody who with
courting who were trying to kind of
satisfy its effectively customer service
yeah it's rather than being an
exploitative practice you can frame it
in a way that is like okay this person
likes this thing that we built how do we
kind of how do we keep them happy how do
we ensure that like they're feeling like
they're valued how do we kind of
continue to make them engaged to justify
the fact that they're willing to engage
and kind of invest in our product in
this way and just that subtle change in
even language really I think has changed
the mentality quite a bit I was a whale
in ours younger I spent you know tens of
thousands of dollars on CDs I'd go out
to the store and buy a music each week I
mean I was a music whale I mean I'm sure
most of you have a hobby
spent far too much money on if that's
focused on a single game I mean as long
if that game has enough content and is
keeping people engaged at that level
like people are happy to spend their
money on what they enjoy doing so do you
guys think that you know micro
transaction systems will become more you
know generally accepted as time goes on
yeah what I recently went to China and
there there talked about in their mobile
games that you know it's just accepted
that's you know it's it's understood
that you will pay extra for these free
games so do you think is just a matter
of time before it becomes more
commonplace and accepted here I think
it's already commonplace yeah yeah and
in terms of being accepted I think that
it's that's the process that's happening
now again and we still see these sort of
rejections in certain situations in
certain scenarios and I think that's
more down to the mechanics of the micro
transactions and again if players think
that well this is actually just either
really sealing me off from content that
should be available or giving someone an
unfair advantage yeah they'll still push
back and which they should if they feel
that way but I think already becoming
some level of norm as to how that norm
will evolve that's something else but I
don't think they're going away anytime
soon and then I kind of want to switch
gears a little bit and talk about the
activision micro transaction patent that
recently came to light so the idea here
was that they explored a system in the
game or a patent for a system that would
deliberately lead players towards micro
transactions by say you know matching
them with someone who had and you know X
gun or something that and then if that
or a high-level player so when they saw
them perform well you know they might
drive them to want to do that and
Activision later said that they only
explore this you know in a research and
development standpoint but I'm wondering
if you think this is a you know micro
transactions being big business despite
the name do you think this kind of
system is inevitable in games that would
that we might see you know games
purposely driving players toward a
specific item I think that being a are I
remember playing World of Warcraft
around launch and
you know walking past the mailbox in
Orgrimmar and oh my god that's the main
tank for the the the guild of the top
leading guild look at his gear and then
would all stand around and look at what
that player was wearing and that
motivated all us all to to want to play
and and reach those levels it's hardly
new I find patenting the idea patently
ridiculous but it's just like people are
going to you know you see someone for
someone walking beside you maybe they're
wearing a cool jacket it's just it's
just natural really yeah yeah I don't
think it's something really new it's
just that we found new ways to
essentially monetize it or at least
build systems around it but it's it's
it's taking a very old engraving which
is if I see somebody who's achieved
something you know and they're at some
level and I want to get there how do I
get there and again then it's a case
about am I getting there by actually
succeeding and being good at the game or
having skill or am I just spending money
to get there again that's where people
can draw the line I think the story made
it worse than what it actually was it
sounded super insidious yeah I mean one
of the things about it is that I think I
think that specifically is quite
insidious and I say that as somebody who
is a data scientist and kind of building
systems like this with that said having
a patent on it is actually really
interesting because technically what
that has done is take that technique out
of everybody's toolbox so nobody but
Activision
could use that as a technique nominally
it's a back-end thing so how would you
ever know but you know legally nobody
but Activision can do it and Activision
have said that they don't want to they
said that they just patented it coupe
say it was R&D it's kind of an
interesting space to be in in that like
theoretically now nobody can do this
thing and it did feel kinda blackhat to
make is like mmm the distinction between
like you organically come across
somebody with gear and kind of want to
actively kind of go it gives you this
kind of star in the sky to chase yep is
really
good artificially kind of setting up
situation through matchmaking to kind of
create that environment where you're
going to be kind of way oh I want that
sniper rifle therefore I'll paid money
for it you know I don't know if you can
say it's more insidious than its you
know it sounds pretty insidious but I
think you've hit it on the head there if
you want to abuse the system you can and
then it's about being called out on it
and yeah and some if you know maybe some
developers will try and take that chance
and take the risk that's you know if
that's a risk they're willing to take
another really interesting topic these
days is loot boxes it's already been
mentioned today on this panel you know
obviously popular and controversial I
think part of it
there is feels that way you know the
psychology and the behavior of you know
holding down a button and waiting for
the with the box to open that thriller
you get right before it opens in the
randomization of what you might find in
there so I'm just wearing if you guys
get me to talk about the this trend of
loot boxes because we saw in you know
Star Wars Battlefront twos beta
there's and they're in there obviously
and then that system was called out more
so than an overwatch which I think
people will generally agree handles that
in a more player friendly way just so
I've not seen the battlefront 2 beta so
I have no idea what they do I think that
it's loop box is a really interesting
problem in some ways it's about you know
on the on the design side it's more
about kind of spinning out content than
anything else you know we can kind of
have you chase a few really cool things
and it's a low drop rate and everybody
acknowledges it's a low drop rate so
like you know you know you're not gonna
get it and you can grind through the
loot boxes you can spend through the
lose boxes but at the same time like
it's something for you to chase I don't
think they're gonna go away anytime soon
and I don't necessarily as a player and
as a dev I don't know that that's a
problem well I think my understanding of
well with the issue with the battlefront
to loot boxes is that there were
questions around there were things in
there that actually would
impact your ability to win in the game
which is always gonna be something which
is gonna be controversial and you know
the loot box is an overwatch by
definition are purely cosmetic and you
know the custom cosmetic of
customization is a great tool to
personalize your game doesn't imply
gameplay do I think loot boxes and that
constant or necessarily in that in that
context or the best way to do it you
know again that's personal approach
right living in and working in gaming in
Japan for the last nine or ten years you
know I mean obviously they've taken loot
boxes in the Gacha systems and so on to
very refined depth and and it's
interesting how you see players now who
spend more time in the Gacha systems and
they do in the actual games a lot of the
streamers that I follow in Japan will
spend most their time streaming them
opening loop boxes and that's the part
that they find exciting that is a thrill
that's where they want to spend their
money do we say to them hey loo boxes
are evil you shouldn't be doing that you
should play the game you know so I mean
galaxy of Heroes you get to a point
where the loot box collection is the
game right now a lot of the games a lot
of those games their end game basically
becomes that you know it's getting those
rare items and getting those you know so
those rare customizations and sharing it
with your friends and being the cool guy
who actually managed to get it and so on
so is that the future of gaming I don't
think so
but it's certainly a certain part of
gaming where which players do you know
some players see value and enjoy I think
hmm don't meet for single-player games
when you're throwing loot boxes in there
as a way of getting through that that
definitely raises some eyebrows compared
to like ah it's a tough one I mean I
bought ten loot boxes this morning you
know overwatch because uh I didn't get
to play these Heloise I really wanted to
Halloween in these times sort of things
like I'm totally ok with that whereas
you know my wife and daughter didn't
have to buy loot boxes because they had
time to play this month but uh every
every free-to-play mechanism has a
chance to mess with game design and I
think in a sink in single-player games
it's more obvious than ever like what's
going to happen there it's it's going to
there's a very good chance of you
breaking a single-player game but of
course I mean the best ways for us to
deal with that is consumers is a speak
out about it and B don't buy the game
the next time and you'll quickly find
that the things you don't like go away
or the game itself goes away because
they needed loot boxes to support it in
the first place so yeah it's a bit of a
weird time but I think you hit on
something as well about time and the
ability to spend time on games and
especially there's so much content now
on so many different ways you can spend
your time and some people they still
want to be involved in the game they
don't have ten hours to spend playing a
specific game but maybe they can spend a
certain amount of money and it gets them
to still access some of the things that
they would like as someone who able to
be able to spend those 10 hours is that
a bad thing you know I mean they still
want those items they still want those
things yeah I still want that then
you're not asked in which I did not get
so we've got about 15 minutes so if
people want to start lining up for
questions now if you have any there's
there's microphones on either side of
the room but all just gets things
started here with what I asked you guys
how do you see market transaction
systems you know evolving over time I
know you've said you know it's in a
state of constant change but what are
the things you think around maybe the
immediate horizon stop do my own think
wait I mean you just want to play like
for me playing a lot of games and I got
we've done it we've done a bit of read
in the future I mean we were an
innovator we've with cross he Road and
and and the rejection of the whale
culture but um successes like that are
far and a far and few between it's
pretty difficult to predict the future I
think you'll just start to see you know
loot boxes will probably go through some
evolution probably someone will go too
far take it too far
it'll pull back something else will come
what that is that's gonna be it's hard
to say it yeah it's it's a tough one
really if they're not fun to open people
won't open them right we'll start with
questions on this side of the room go
ahead sir um I was just curious
other than stuff that's blatantly
pay2win and horse armor what's the
cheapest most underhanded or evilest
micro transaction or free-to-play model
you've ever seen well I think the
Blizzard know that I'm a Zenyatta main
and refused to give me zenyatta skins if
anyone is here from Activision you know
go to help horse armor was pretty bad
yeah but that was like one of the first
ones then they could horse there I mean
horse armor wouldn't feel so bad today
honestly I think energy was probably one
of the worst ones paying to you know you
you're basically saying hey stop playing
our game and then pay for it and then
you know oh then you get to play for
five more minutes and it was kind of I
mean yeah the whole Facebook my entire
Asian model was just yeah I need to be
careful that Rossi roads loop box is a
quiet quite a lot like an energy system
I mean it's sort of encouraging you to
take a break and come back later and
you'll get some more stuff I mean
there's lots of ways of doing energy the
energy does work though I mean if people
just like with with pac-man we probably
should have had something that felt a
bit more energy because people played it
a lot and they never played it again
which is not what you want you want
people to enjoy it for a long period of
time yeah well the way the way the clash
RL handled that was like you could pick
up four chests and then you can you
could keep playing but you weren't gonna
get the rewards anymore I really didn't
like that the first time I played and I
warm to it over
the first 24 hours I'm like okay I think
I see what they're doing I guess I'll
keep playing later thank you for your
question we'll go over to the side now
thank you
hey guys are going so my question mainly
revolves around the trend that we're
seeing with certain dames where they
start you know incorporating
microtransactions
as a substitute for season passes seen
it in games such as dlc in general
Sienna did overwatch with the loot boxes
we saw it in time for - recently where
they you know who said all post released
content that effects the game will be
free but the cosmetics is you know going
to be you know it's gonna cost and now
we're seeing it with Star Wars
Battlefront - except you know the
progression of the game is apart of the
loot boxes so what's your thoughts on
that whole trend that we're seeing you
know because you know you run into the
issue of you know is there really as
much value in a RNG loot box in the form
of microtransaction when you could be
offering proper DLC assuming that it is
actual dears so you're not been cut out
of the game to be you know oh just
played up where do we get on that one
yeah I think it's a good question it's
it comes down to again you know
obviously the DLC model came pretty much
first for a lot of these titles as a way
to to extend the life cycle of the game
then we've got into these season passes
to basically in right in my view season
passes is a way to lock you into those
DLCs and basically whether you're
actually willing to commit to the game
at that level and friendly before you
even plated okay so now I'm walking into
four DLCs pre-order DLC essentially
sorry pre-ordering DLC is right um you
know I've done that for destiny too and
I'm asking myself was that the right
thing to do you know when I see what I
got from the get-go so yeah it's a tough
question because you know on the one
hand you're talking about something
which personally me gives you value like
like you know customizations for your
characters fundamentally you can play
the whole game and enjoy the whole game
and not have to worry about it
where's is something which is directly
impacting the amount of time you spend
on the gun at game I mean with the
caveat that I think in general I would I
think we would all say probably that
loot boxes should never have stuff
that's kind of the beta win
never you know and if we get to that
stage that's when you know I would
expect players to revolt and you know
players are always revolting to Terraria
is really interesting two areas really
interesting one where the developers
refused to put DLC in it because it
means it'll split the the market people
can't immediately you know join in and
you keeping the community together by
not having DLC but of course that games
you know could have made a lot more
money and they could have hired more
staff and more updates you know they
were you know they killed that game for
a little while there before they came
back to Italy a year and a half later so
you know there's it's just pros and cons
to everything really what if this said
no actually just answer my question so
my question comes with loot boxes and
problem gambling you know how do you
identify players who spend too much and
you know how do you stop your game just
being a loop box opening simulator or
just the dis that slot machine as
opposed to a racing game all that
awesome adventure game I'll take that
one to begin with so problem gambling is
something that's really important for me
personally like we've we've Crossy roads
we ban all ads for you know anything
that looks like a casino you're not
allowed to see those ads in our game and
we'll shut down our providers who do it
of course we have a random chance
no simulator and Crossy road but for me
you know 10% of the population is going
to be addicted to to gambling we don't
want to expose those people to it I'd
like to think that Crossy road is not a
substitute for for someone who wants to
go to the pokies and turn their life
around
it's said I if there's not a possibility
of winning money then that that's how I
draw the line that's how I draw our line
but
you know other people will approach it
differently and then there's other
people who really don't care at all like
you know problem gambling is not a
problem so again it's I think possibly
government legislation would would help
in this case and let people know fair
country what should and shouldn't be
allowed and I've done that in China
first and I think it's kind of countries
I think it's coming and I think it's
it's a natural evolution as well you
know once you get these more and more
complex mechanics and we've seen some
mechanics being banned in certain
countries because it just really is very
close to to gambling and it's and so far
away from what a game should be you know
we've built our mechanics basically
avoiding most of those concepts just
because we don't need them in the game
for the most part and I think sometimes
you can do them for you know short times
or have them as a special event you know
yes it's something that some players won
and some players enjoy so again it's how
you how you build it and how you build
it into your game design and if you
start building it as a core of your game
design you're getting into very
dangerous territory I think potentially
thanks for the question go to this
segment just quickly thank you for doing
this a very controversial topic and I
admire the ability to sit in for our
crowd of people and actually address
this I had a question regarding the
devil I have a question in regards to
crunch do you think microtransactions
can make that crunch period worse or in
some cases make it better by taking the
pressure of a deadline I think with
overwatch it kind of feels like
sometimes they're stuck in permanent
crunch
constant releasing content a treadmill
more than crunch yeah so does it make it
in your cases better or worse kind of
help or yeah so I used to make a little
single-player games making a game with a
treadmill is a lot harder like I've
personally struggled quite a lot with it
keeping Crossy Road you know attempting
to kick cross he wrote a life for so
long we're normally a go or some hit
game great now I can make the next one
it's been it's been fairly draining to
continue to keep that game alive yeah I
mean like with it's a you know our game
is is is big and broad and and has a lot
of content and there's a lot of demand
for new content and we're constantly
pushing new content and game modes and
we have guys working on it around the
clock essentially um I don't think loot
boxes per se have an impact on that it's
it feels free to play the loot boxes
yeah it's the free to play it's the game
as a service model where you're you know
you're basically supporting the title
24/7 it changes the concept of crunch in
a way because as you mentioned it's more
of this treadmill the sort of continuous
and ongoing exercise yeah but you can
rotate that I mean you don't to do a we
didn't just have two people working on a
paradigm sharing the rotate the teams
around you yeah so there are ways in
there ways you work around it and then
you keep also people fresh and have
fresh ideas you know when you're working
on the same title for a long time you
can get locked into a certain mindset so
I think blue box is it's it's kind of a
separate thing yes it can it can affect
in the sense that you're having to
potentially create new content
specifically for those little boxes if
that's what you're doing
which again is another topic I would
think is you know if you're building a
whole separate entity just to create
content for loot box that you know
that's another girl that's another grind
another treadmill that you've got
somebody else running on but so to
disagree a little bit yep you do get a
lot more control over the speed at which
people can get through the content
simply because you've got much more
control over the mass at which you'd rip
it out through the loop boxes so I think
I think you can do it in such a way that
it's probably a little bit of a shift
but it is it's more of a shift than it
is a solve and the other thing to keep
in mind is that it probably the the
treadmill that you're describing is
specifically an asset read law at that
point correct which means that you know
you'd not necessarily grinding through
features at the rate we would have to
wait for a single game yeah but we can
definitely kind of I feel like loot
boxes give us an opportunity to kind of
say okay we're gonna front load this
much content with I'm gonna do this this
this and this and then we're gonna drop
into what we call bold beats which are
effectively new features but with less
kind of stretched on that as a result of
being able to trip content out through a
mechanism like a loop
okay great thank you for the question
we'll go to this side now thank you
what's your opinion on the possible
oversaturation with marking transactions
as such a play industry seems to be
obsessed with short-term games
short-term gains over long-term game
gains and it could like have potential
long-term effects on the gaming of
history it's uh it's just it's what we
were talking about before with the
budget et cetera I mean the publishers
have to solve this problem somehow you
cannot keep getting a bigger and bigger
and bigger game it's it's just
unsustainable so this is this is what
they're trying if it doesn't work
they'll try something else at or they'll
stop making games no I'm good with great
thank you well go to the sender hey get
a fellas hang on once again thanks for a
controversial panel like you sitting up
here essentially defending
microtransactions I like a lot of people
have spent a just a dick ton of money on
this sort of things mr. wargames in
particular I've got like a hundred plus
ships in my port in world of warships
like I think I'm missing one premium and
they dont sell it anymore because it was
just broken his [ __ ] that was the
imperative Nicola
so that's why we don't see her from that
respect a lot of games you've got
microtransactions DLC whatever you want
to call it where it's either not pay2win
call it paid a shortcut paid a side
grade pay for variety something you may
have taste in that's great I'm totally
okay with that I'm gonna harp a little
bit more on the loot boxes in particular
but I'd like to ask you guys a pointed
question in regards to the morality of
it a couple of statements of fact
apologize I'm gonna try and get through
this really quick
it's science marketing is science the
techniques behind gambling exploitation
of human psychological mechanisms and
responses is science when you go as a
producing content specifically around
this the effects are known it's a
formula R in with a known output
essentially how it works and at this
stage of the game you guys still have
the keys to the vault on a very
unregulated set of gambling essentially
how do you feel knowing that these are
elements you're introducing into your
games for profit having full
understanding of how they work
and how do you feel about what will the
never it'll be push back in the future
because it can't stay unregulated for
over and how do you think about tackling
the fine balance where again a question
relating to saturation as the other
gentleman just mentioned there's got to
be a point where if you push it too far
gamers will start fighting back and it's
going to get to the point where they may
even wind up joining hands with the old
arch-nemesis of angry rich white people
sitting in government who love to beat
on video games as soon as a movement
springs up which appeals to these guys
saying we've got some evil video games
people here introducing gambling to our
kids you guys are going to get behind it
and stomp on this there gonna be a lot
of people happy to come down and you're
like a [ __ ] ton of bricks you've got
about 30 seconds left so if you can get
to yes basically like the morality over
being the gambling czar known science
and you're running it in your games how
do you feel this is gonna have to be the
last response guys but we'll be here
after the panel ends to talk a bit more
but it's gonna have to be this response
thank you have a good one to talk about
that so obviously with Crossy road being
a game you
that's played by kids as well it's a bit
like I said it's been super important to
us we don't want to get people to do it
to associate random prizes with we've
gambling and we are not doubt a data
scientist like we know had the most I
knew about before what's going was
Skinner boxes might help it will could
play longer and that's all it is to us
like there is no you can't get money
back out of it in the same way that the
massive controversy with the the steam
valve counter-strike like that's what
that really crossed the line from you
know that's that's genuine and the
probably the most detestable thing I
find in video games is the is the slot
machine simulators that sit on top of
the App Store charts here in Australia
because they are able to you know that
they're made by the same people who make
you know again you know that the same
gambling machines being but of course
you can say okay we're going to make the
odds here in the game where people can't
win money really good and then they'll
take their skills to the casino and you
know get their life savings to go away I
absolutely agree with you that
government legislation needs to to come
in and I I'm interested in having that
dialogue with anyone who wants to talk
to me but again that's just these are my
opinions and my own you know live battle
lines that I draw based on my own
experiences and and other people are the
same like my uncle but can't people can
you know people can do whatever they
want if they won't again will their life
savings were a good luck long but I do
not take that approach because I know
that some people just can't help
themselves what are kids yeah yeah
Thanks
yes
all random chance is not gambling in my
opinion you know that anyone can talk
about that at any level but but yeah it
is super important to us that we you
know we take feedback very regularly
about these sorts of things right we're
gonna have to cut it off there but thank
you guys so much for coming out today
and let's give a hand for our panelists
please
you